okay okay well um I appreciate you
sitting down and talking to me yeah I
mean you've been going for a while yeah
I see you out here doing this but I I'm
just wondering like for myself who I
watched you do this
um a few a few different interviews
um but I'm just wondering like what
exactly are you getting from these kind
of conversations do you find that you
yourself are learning more about people
or are you just kind of pushing the
agenda
because to me like honestly I just heard
kind of like you're sticking to the same
talking points and I didn't really hear
a lot of like discussion from your end
to me I just get public opinions on
stuff so I just get people's public
opinions and I also to Bro a lot of the
reason I do what I do is I advocate for
men's rights so I have two brothers that
like committed they tried to commit
suicide so I just think the world is
harder for men than the media really
lets it